tom how surprised were you when the news
broke today that cam newton is staying
with the patriots were you giving us a
reprise of your
shocked face from this morning when you
saw that cam is staying
no you know it's funny last night i've
had a creeping sense that this was
getting closer and closer just in the
people i speak to down there
are starting to say look there's nothing
out there for free agents
and trying to sell the notion that kim
wasn't that
bad when you really look at it there
were a lot of things beyond his control
that kind of contributed to things so i
was prepared for it i
targeted it last night mike at 51
likelihood that kim would be back but i
thought that that was going to be
in case of emergency break glass
maybe in june if they couldn't get
anybody else i didn't think it was going
to happen now
so we mean you just kind of oh go ahead
miles
this is the first thing it's the first
time miles and i have done this so we
got to get our sea legs
we're going to go back and forth with
questions tom i hope you're ready to get
grilled go ahead miles
thank you mike uh so well tommy you kind
of just alluded to this
that people were saying it wasn't
necessarily all cam's fault but from
your perspective i mean was
the offense last year a cam newton
problem or was it a receiver's problem
was it both it was both but here's the
thing
it was probably worse personnel wise in
2020
than it was in 2019 miles the reason
being
in 2019 you had julian edelman on a
100-catch
thousand-yard season cam didn't have
that
now brady had a worse offensive line to
deal with in 2019 but he also had james
white they didn't have an offseason to
get those tight ends going i don't know
if they'll ever get going or not but
i would say that the patriots in 2019
might have had a better
complement of players neither was good
but here's the thing that people are
overlooking what the patriots
do shine a light on if everybody around
the quarterback is that
challenged well then how do you make up
for it you make up for it with the feet
and that's what cam did 12 touchdowns on
the ground
55 55 first downs that he picked up on
the ground
so those are things they look at and say
look if brady was here
and he was facing third and three we
couldn't have run with him but we could
with cam
tom jimmy garoppolo's name had been
linked to the patriots greg bedard
recently said that he was plan a
was this just a case of the patriots not
wanting to take the chance of waiting
for garoppolo and maybe not getting him
so they better take
cam while they can before he signs
elsewhere
i think that's 100 accurate and i think
the cam was of a mind too that
you know what let's let's not let's not
screw around with this
i want to be here you guys need a
quarterback i'd love to run it back
again with you guys i enjoyed it
and i'll take another modest contract
that if i play like i think i can play
we're going to make a little bit more i
don't think the patriots are by any
stretch and i'm sure
both of you guys are are in the same
boat are
done it's a five million dollar contract
that's less than marcus mariota made to
pack up derek carr last year
so to me the patriots have just kind of
done what they did with trent brown
earlier this week it's really a cover
your ass type of move
if he's starting on opening day and i
just put this out on twitter
i don't think the patriots will be giddy
about that that means nobody beat them
out
nobody shook loose from anyplace else
but at least they feel okay that they
have a guy that they don't dislike
playing the position so does that mean
you anticipate that they will either
draft a quarterback
or add somebody else in free agency that
is
going to give cam some up some
competition
or miles they find somebody to shake
loose somehow deshawn watson goes to san
francisco and they convince jimmy
garoppolo
to give up his no trade clause take a
pay cut and come here
then maybe they can work it but i think
right now it is tbd
they have to and that's one that's
interesting thing about belichick is he
doesn't
pinch himself into a corner too often i
could argue
you do have to be a little bit more
proactive than he has been offensively
really since 2017 because he's only
drafted
jimmy garoppolo and danny etling
reacquired brian hoyer and now has twice
signed cam newton i don't think that
that is
really being urgent at the position but
you have to allow it to play out
somewhat over the next few months
and allow yourself some some some
mobility
so that if you do have an early onset
stutter as i just did
you can recover quickly and then finish
the sentence
here's the the concern i have though as
it relates to the possibility it'll be
jimmy garoppolo or someone else who
could potentially supplant cam newton as
the starter
when i see the accurate details not the
stuff that came out earlier that cam
newton is making close to 14 million but
when it's a base package of five and
it's nine million in incentives
that are premised on the guy actually
playing don't you read that at some
level as an implication that it's his
gig that it's his job that they're
signing him with the understanding
that he's number one and they're not
going to actively go out and look for
someone who could just
take that job over walking through the
door
yeah you could take that implication or
you could take it at
you know as we're hedging our bets cam
you we're not giving you the job you
have to win it and he had to win it last
year
his competition was only jared stidham
but i still think he would have to win
it
and if you're cam newton and you're
going to say i don't think there's 32
quarterbacks better than me
and they hustle gartner minshew in here
or somebody and i don't think they're
going to do that
you're going to think you're going to
beat him out now garoppolo would be
certainly you know a horse of a
different color in terms of what
level and classification of quarterback
former super bowl
starter is but
i still think the 5 million base is 5
million based
that is not the going rate for a
starting quarterback and the patriots
have hedged their bets well with it
what other offensive positions do you
think really should be the priority for
the patriots going into this offseason
free agency
miles i think that they really i mean
it's obvious the wide receiver is
is a huge glaring hole for them and
i don't know i think jacoby myers didn't
have a touchdown reception damier byrd
might have had one
wish i had the numbers right in front of
me and probably could google it and find
them but
their wide receiver touchdowns were very
very very low
certainly less than five as for tight
end production it was non-existent
they're two guys that they drafted
what what what
you're good okay my bad you said
anything i'm sorry they just did a wipe
and i got screwed
uh they have a tight end production
between the two rookies that they
drafted
logan keane and devon asiassi have like
six catches for the year
for the year and ryan izzo didn't bring
anything either so it's got to be wide
receiver and tight end that they start
with
and i just don't know i mean we've seen
the trials and tribulations of them
trying to get
things right at those positions so
it's hard to have great faith that
they're gonna get it right
hey tom one more about the patriots
before we pivot to
the patriots former starting quarterback
the
salary cap surplus that the patriots
have significant
puts them in a position to sign a lot of
guys bargain basement guys it's not like
they're going to go out and making a
dailiest thomas stefan gilmore type
signing next week and of course now that
i've said that they probably will
how much of what they have now
how much of that was deliberate last
year when they kind of saw which way the
wind was blowing
they knew that there were going to be
significant pandemic losses they had
eight guys i think it was
opt out for the year how much did they
decide screw it we're just going to
stockpile cash and cap space for next
year
and we're going to go ahead and and
try to take full strategic and
competitive advantage
of the fact that so many teams are going
to be scrambling next year to comply
with the cap
and we're going to be able to go all in
and
and put together a championship team
with bargain basement players
serendipity michael i think it was
totally and wholly serendipity that it
worked out that way for them
um because if you look
as brady was entering free agency around
march 17th
and the team was franchising joe tooney
to the tune of 15 million dollars they
were bumping up against the cap what
they had hoped to do was
to resign brady to reconfigure toonie's
contract bring his number down
keep him around um the fact that
they ended up cleaning their books off
when they lost brady
and i would say lose lost him um
they in one fell swoop were able to
write their books and also
you know benefit from the dropping cap
around the league with other people
being thrown overboard
is just good fortune good timing on
their part hard to call a pandemic good
timing
but they end up being the beneficiaries
of that
to a large extent
so when you now see tom brady has signed
this extension that will
let him play essentially until he's at
least 45 with the tampa bay buccaneers
are you at all surprised by the way that
this has gone down
no i mean this is part and parcel miles
of what he has always done with the new
england patriots and
you know if the patriots had negotiated
in what brady and don yee would have
considered
to be good faith in 2017 after jimmy
garoppolo was traded
in 2018 in 2019
he would have done these deals which
would have then resulted in him
perhaps renegotiating to drop the number
down if need be that's the way he's kind
of always done it i think one time
and that was in 2010 he had the top of
the market
contract in 2013 that's when the
patriots and brady got together and i
think it was a six year
maybe not even uh 60 million extension i
would have to double check that and i
should because i've said it twice now on
television and not gotten it right um
but bob kraft called that the elegant
solution to brady's contract where he
wouldn't take up too much cap space and
they could still build around him
only when the patriots became hesitant
about
keeping him around and making him go
with incentive laden deals that he had
no shot at getting
did he then begin to say let's have 25
million here
you know let's start to pay me closer to
the market but it was only because he
didn't trust what they were doing where
he started to say
if you're going to make me go year to
year i want to be paid more
tom on the scale of no big deal
garden variety early regular season loss
to
super bowl 42 losing to the giants where
will it fall
if the patriots lose at home to tom
brady and the buccaneers this year
whenever that game may be
i think it'll be no big deal barely
causes a ripple
um because you're talking about the
super bowl champions against
you know what is a team that came off a
7-9 season and who knows what the record
will be then
to me it would be much much much much
more poetic justice if there was a way
for the patriots to rest jimmy garoppolo
free from san francisco
and have brady the deposed prince
coming back from exile to battle against
the the aging king and his
he's always preferred prince jimmy
garoppolo
and fight for their honor fields of
battle at gillette stadium
um wait but i don't think it's gonna
happen but would it be an issue though
if you know brady comes in and he's
playing with the buccaneers
and all of a sudden the new england
crowd starts chanting brady brady brady
because
the buccaneers are just doing their
thing against the patriots
oh yeah and you know what there will be
fights in the stands because this has
in a way that bled so brady did not
because that was a team that was
you know there was a lot of loyalty to
drew bledsoe
in 2000 and 2001 but he still wasn't a
winning quarterback
certainly to the level that brady was
nor did he put them on the map nor
provide them with a
surname or a first name to give to dogs
cats and children for years to come
if brady comes in and does that kind of
pees on
the patriots foreheads bill belichick's
forehead
i think that the people who take some
gratification
from seeing that bill made a mistake and
brady is showing him what a great
mistake it was
will be in great conflict on that day
with the people who say and bill we
trust brady was
a petulant child and um
bill gave him everything that he turned
out to be and that is
almost how it splits right now there is
very very very few who are in that
that middle it's blue state red state
you decide which one is which
hey tom one more for you and we
appreciate your time as always
if i'm reading you properly based upon
the last 10 minutes or so and there's a
chance i'm not
i get the impression that you don't view
last year's seven and nine as some sort
of uh
regrouping by the patriots you
see it more as the start of a trend and
that this team has its work
cut out for it to be a playoff team
again is that fair to say
absolutely i think the ceiling is
probably about ten and six
um in a team that can overachieve give a
hard time to some really good teams get
its ass handed to it by the very
good teams and beat all the teams that
are similar to it they went 7-9 last
year with one of the worst rosters in
football
it won't be one of the worst rosters in
football this year just with the
opt-outs coming back
but they still don't have anybody who
makes you sweat in the front seven
except for dante hightower
they may lose to stefan gilmore via
trade or something else
no wide receivers no tight ends and a
quarterback
right now who's not really good at
throwing overhand
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports